well look i mean he has made clear
that uh uh
hey that guy is going to stand up to a
kgb train killer like vladimir putin
the answer is i just don't think it's
going to happen
and this is the biggest problem joe
biden is not
all there now theoretically he could be
not all there but his
team could be staffed by a bunch of
hawks who really are going to face up to
the threat that russia poses
and remember according to the democrats
until the last 35 seconds
when joe biden became president russia
was the chief threat to the united
states now they said that
of course because they were focused in
over and over and over on the idea that
donald trump was somehow being bribed to
be president by vladimir putin that he
was a manchurian candidate
or the moscow candidate but now that
biden's president
they're like you know what it would be
great if we cut our military and you
know what if we put out some like
recruiting videos for the military that
featured lesbian moms i mean that seems
like a great way to recruit for the
military and for the cia what if we like
really targeted the group of people who
are thinking about applying to the cia
but suffer from generalized anxiety
disorder that's like that's where we got
to put our time
and our effort and also we really have
to consider whether military bases
should fly the pride flag i mean
these are really important subjects for
the united states military in the face
of increased russian aggression and
meanwhile you've got that administration
topped
by a person whose brain is just not
functioning okay i'm sorry
the media are not going to show you
these clips they will not show you these
clips
on cbs evening news because they are
extremely disquieting
and honestly you have to feel bad for
the president of the united states who
at this point
seems to be the victim of elder abuse
they are trotting out a person who he
does not have his faculties about him
if you've ever had an elderly relative
who's starting to lose it joe biden is
your elder
elderly relative who's starting to lose
it i actually feel bad for the man
he is in a high pressure situation the
highest pressure job on planet earth and
he is clearly
not capable of handling himself it's
honestly he's my president too right
he's your president he's the elected
president
you don't want the elected president to
not have the ability to even speak
here was joe biden yesterday i mean
there's an unbelievable clip
here is joe biden yesterday asked about
whether vladimir putin is a killer now
he to preface this clip to backtrack for
a moment
understand that in march joe biden did
an interview in which he was asked
whether vladimir putin was a killer and
he said
absolutely here was joe biden just a
couple of months ago saying that
vladimir putin was a killer
most important thing dealing with
foreign leaders in my experience and
i've dealt with an awful lot of
my career is just know the other guy
so you know vladimir putin you think
he's a killer mm-hmm
i do okay so pretty swift answer there
with his good friend george
stephanopoulos
here was yesterday okay remember this
has only been a three month gap this is
this is a guy
in a serious state of mental decline i
mean
i don't know what else to tell you i'm
only looking at the evidence of my eyes
i'm not a doctor i'm not gonna pretend
i'm a doctor
all i can tell you is that if you've
ever seen a person who is sliding down
the hill
in terms of his faculties joe biden
looks an awful lot like that
remember that was him with george
stephanopoulos in march here is
here is president joe biden in june
being asked the same question
answer the first question i'm laughing
too
they actually uh
well look i mean he has made clear that
uh
the answer is i believe he is in the
past
essentially acknowledged that he was uh
there are certain things that he would
do or did do
but look um when i was asked that
question
on air i answered it honestly but it's
not
much of a i i i don't think it matters a
whole lot in terms of this next meeting
we're about to have
okay first of all very weak answer but
second of all
that is a full six and a half second gap
in that tape
where he's just standing there not
knowing what's going on around him
okay that guy is gonna stand up to a kgb
train killer like vladimir putin
i hope he does he's my president too
again i would love to see the president
of the united states take a hard
strong stance with regards to the
russians i just don't think it's going
to happen
and joe biden was also asked by the way
about russia and
and he referred to russia as quote
unquote our adversary and or
our possible adversary again it's just
that
he is he is now arnold schwarzenegger in
total recall
wearing the the lady disguise when it
starts to glitch
i mean you're afraid that his head is
going to start opening up right that's
that's what
he's going to start shaking all over the
place and then he's going to explode
into arnold schwarzenegger
it's so weird here here's the president
of the united states
i've been doing this a long time yes you
have the last thing
anyone would do is negotiate in front of
the world press
as to how he's going to approach a
critical meeting
with another adversary and or
someone who could be an adversary so
last thing i'm going to do
that's yes great okay well meanwhile
china is on the move as well biden's
being tested
so far not seen a lot from joe biden i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the ben
shapiro show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button so you stay up to
date with all our future
content